the upgrade is mine
but I'm already eligible oh it's off
okay fine that was actually shot with a
real pro camera roll the iPhone pro okay
that's enough of that we decided to
shoot some of this review with the
iPhone 11 but not all of it this is
still a review though of the newest
iPhones cameras well because that's
pretty much the most interesting thing
about them the new $700 iPhone 11 $1,000
iPhone 11 pro and $1100 iPhone 11 pro
max look and feel like last year's
iPhones right there's a new magical
midnight green color
look I've coordinated for the first time
in my life the iPhone 11 is the reworked
iPhone 10 armed with a wide camera and
an ultra-wide camera and a bit more
battery life the iPhone 11 pro and pro
max which are just the same phones just
different sizes now have wide and ultra
wide cameras plus a telephoto and lots
more battery life than last year's 10s
models and that's why I'm here to put
these cameras to the test and see which
one takes the throne and compare it to
some older iPhones it doesn't really
matter if this is just slightly better
than last year's but what if you have an
iPhone 6 or 7 or 8 the New York
Renaissance Fair has all the scenes you
possibly could want to test the cameras
colorful people battles for making short
movies weird animals for testing new pet
portrait mode it's also good for testing
battery life since there's no electrical
outlets anywhere
[Music]
test one out revive after testing these
phones for the last week I'm most
excited about the ultra wide camera
lenses hey got the ultra wide wide now
the telephoto just compare these two
shots then compare this shot to the one
I took with the iPhone 8 and the iPhone
6 not only can you capture more of a
scene but you can also frame some pretty
artistic shots
verily tests tool for its load all three
of the new iPhones have portrait mode
and what better way to test than with a
visit to the Queen are these these
magical pixie boxes that everyone is
talking about yes you have one new you
can see them all about the Shire there's
many many persons screaming into their
pixie boxes as you can still hear me
lady Johanna okay the phone's wide
cameras have new sensors and improved
HDR which help make the shots a bit
crisper and balanced though the software
still struggles around the edges of
sharp objects this one is from Samsung
have you heard of Samsung the big
improvement on the pro models is that
you can now use portrait mode on the
standard wide lens as well as on the
telephoto lens and unlike last year's
iPhone 10 are the iPhone 11 now lets you
shoot portrait mode with your favorite
pet which is obviously a kookaburra burp
test 3 video as you saw at the beginning
video quality looks better than previous
iPhones but it's still nowhere near as
nice as a real dedicated pro camera at
least not without any special gear or
apps but for capturing your basic
everyday life moments the new cameras
are great
all three iPhones have improved
stabilization so I decided to give that
a test would you like to test an iPhone
this may not be my best idea
as you can see the iPhone 11 pros
footage is still jumpy and bumpy but a
lot smoother than last year's the big
change though is that you can now change
to a different lens when recording a
video it's nice for zooming in and out
of a scene just full night mode one of
the coolest promoted features of these
phones night mode thank you for inviting
me in when the phone senses a low light
environment it automatically switches on
night mode when you press the shutter
button the phone takes a moment to take
a number of shots in the background and
then combine them into a better lit
photo it works really well if you're
holding incredibly still and so are your
subjects and it compares quite well to
the Google pixel 3 in situations where
there's movement you can still use the
flash or disable night mode altogether
which is way too much of a hassle the
way the software is designed regular
low-light shots are also really improved
before the Sun sets let's talk about
battery life all three of these phones
last the full day that is no need to
charge them even if you come to a place
like this and beat the crap out of the
cameras the 11pro max lasted the longest
in my tests I am the queen and the
iPhone 11 is the iPhone I'd recommend to
most people in fact if you don't care
about many of these new camera features
I actually recommend the iPhone 10 are
from last year which cost up in
technology less than the 11 if you
really want that telephoto lens for when
shooting video and photos the starting
at $1000 Pro holds the camera throne but
remember next year there's likely to be
another new iPhone and that's when the
real Renaissance witchcraft